Thanks to CuriosityStream for supporting this
episode!
Go to CuriosityStream.com/microcosmos to start
streaming thousands of documentaries and for
a special offer that helps support our show.
Our world is made up of invisible highways.
They intersect and divert and congest, taking
organisms on short trips and long voyages
alike in a flurry of activity.
Now, we may not be able to see all of those
highways laid out, the way commuters might
see long stretches of concrete stacked on
each other.
But we can start to see their outlines in
the lives that are traced upon those roads.
The microcosmos is no exception.
In fact, it is where all those journeys begin.
When Antonie van Leeuwenhoek made his first
observations of microbes, he was captivated
by those primitive paths, even though he didn’t
know what he was observing.
He didn’t even know what creatures he was
observing.
He wrote, “…the motion of most of these
animalcules in the water was so swift, and
so various upwards, downwards and round about
that ’twas wonderful to see.”
Leeuwenhoek hired a draughtsman to help draw
what he observed.
And sharing his employer’s delight, the
draughtsman reportedly exclaimed, “Oh, that
one could ever depict so wonderful a motion!”
He probably did it in Dutch but you get the
idea.
The turn of the 18th century was not a particularly
great time for video.
But fortunately, times have changed, and now
we have ways to depict so wonderful a motion.
And that means we can share things like this,
a band of bacteria—or really more like a
cylinder of thousands of bacteria—that have
gathered for some unseeable reason that must
be important to them.
We think—though we can’t quite be sure—that
the culprit is oxygen.
James, our master of microscopes, kept the
slides in a humidity chamber that was low
in oxygen—an environment that was well-suited
for these bacteria.
But when he took the slide out to check it
under the microscope, oxygen began to seep
in from the sides.
And while many organisms love oxygen, these
bacteria do not.
And with their habitat being slowly encroached
upon by the gas, the bacteria gathered in
the middle of the slide where the oxygen is
lower.
If you take a quick glance, the band of bacteria
seems pretty orderly.
But it just takes a few more seconds to see
that it is made up of chaos, bacteria that
are swimming and wiggling around in what seems
like a completely undirected fashion.
Except, of course, it is directed.
They’re navigating inside an invisible road
shaped by oxygen.
In 1882, the scientist Theodor Wilhelm Engelmann
used a microscope designed by Carl Zeiss himself
to watch algae as they photosynthesized.
But it wasn’t just the algae he was interested
in.
Engelmann also watched as oxygen-loving bacteria
congregated to the areas where algae lay,
seeking out the oxygen byproduct of their
neighbor’s photosynthetic activity.
Engelmann’s work provided descriptions of
bacteria changing their behavior around invisible chemicals.
But it would take a contemporary of his, and
then several decades of waiting, for scientists
to figure out the mechanisms underlying those
changes.
His contemporary was named Wilhelm Pfeffer,
and he designed an experiment using a thin
capillary tube filled with chemical solutions
to study how bacteria gathered first to the
tube, and then inside of it.
After Pfeffer the field becomes quieter until
the middle of the 20th century, when a scientist
named Julius Adler began searching for his
next research project, the one he would pursue
after studying butterflies in college and
rat liver mitochondria in grad school.
It was 1957, and he just happened to be going
through a library filled with old scientific
journals, where he found Pfeffer’s publications.
What he read would end up inspiring decades
of his work, as well as the work of his students,
and colleagues to decipher the chemical and
biological language that bacteria were using
to navigate the world around them.
He established, for instance, that bacteria
are able to detect molecules around them without
actually consuming those molecules, using
receptors at their surface to process and respond.
One student, Mel DePamphilis, used an electron
microscope to capture images of the bacteria’s
motor, called the flagella.
Later, he would say, “I was so excited I
could not take photos but kept thinking, ‘My
God, I’m the first person to see this.’”
A tiny peek behind the curtain, there’s
a note on the script here, and James, our
Master of Microscopes has made a comment,
and he says, “Aha!
This happens to me all the time!”
What a joyous feeling that must be, but also
look, all of us together are seeing that thing
that Mel DePamphilis first saw all those decades
ago and it is no less remarkable for having
been seen by others.
Anyway, over time, what became apparent is
that the flagella doesn’t just move bacteria,
because swimming in the microcosmos is kind
of difficult when you’re small.
The water is thick, like honey.
But what the bacteria’s combination of flagella
and receptors do is let the organism move
randomly…but also purposefully.
The systems can vary among different bacteria—they
do, after all, have different needs from their
environments but so much of what we know comes
from studies of E. coli.
And in E. coli, the movement of the flagella
dictates whether the organism will tumble
around or propel forward.
Now, why would an organism want to tumble?
What does randomly turning about do?
Well, for you and I, tumbling is probably,
at best, not useful, at worst, disorienting,
but for bacteria, it’s a way to get reoriented,
allowing them to point in different directions
until they find the right way forward.
And to determine what the right way is, they
measure gradients, looking for changes in
the amount of those chemicals they either
want to get closer to or further away from.
When those changes point to something good,
the bacteria propels onward.
And when they point to something bad, it tumbles.
They can do this incredibly fast, capable
of speeds that are several hundred body lengths per second.
It’s like sprinting home in the dark, guided
only by the familiar changes in the streets
around you but it is enough to have helped
bacteria survive this world and its many,
many challenges for billions of years.
Of course, it also means that other organisms
have inherited those mechanisms too, like
these ciliates drawn as they are to their
bacterial prey through an invisible connection,
whether or not they knew that’s what drew
them there in the first place.
Because even when the roads are unseen, and
even when we may not know where we’re going,
we can surely figure out what to do when we
get there.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
This episode was brought to you by CuriosityStream,
it’s a subscription streaming service that
offers thousands of documentaries and non­fiction
TV shows from some of the world's best filmmakers,
including award winning exclusives & originals.
They cover topics like history, nature, science,
food, technology, travel, and more!
There, you can watch the documentaries like
“Never Home Alone” where they explore
the unseen wildlife that lives in all of the
nooks and crannies of your home and take a
microscopic journey through your food, cabinets,
and showerheads.
You can stream CuriosityStream’s library,
including their collections of curated programs
handpicked by their experts, to any device
for viewing anytime, anywhere, and if you
go to curiositystream.com/microcosmos and
use the code “Microcosmos” to sign up,
it will only cost you $14.99 for an entire
year!
All of the people on the screen right now,
they are folks that moved through the wondrous
gradients of knowledge and algorithmic suggestions
to find our content and then love it enough
that they wanted to support it so that we
can keep making it and keep making it better.
They’re our patrons on patreon.
You can become one of them by going to patreon.com/journeytomicro.
If you would like to see more from our Master
of Microscopes James Weiss, you can check
out Jam and Germs on Instagram, or you can
see him in Emily Graslie’s new video where
the two of them discuss microscopy and Emily
even painted a painting inspired by some of
the tardigrades you have seen on this very
channel.
And you can go check that out at our link
in the description.
And if you want to see more from us, hey,
there’s always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.